welcome back to new rock stars I'm Eric
Boss and this is a breakdown of the boys
gen V Episode 6 jumaji an episode that
has nothing to do with a magical board
game and everything to do with a
terrifying soup who can trap you inside
her mind and make you relive your worst
moments remember Kate telling Rufus to
hit himself in the crotch with a
baseball bat and Shout was the first
time we saw her user powers on this show
and we are about to see a lot more of
what she can do also both the original
jumaji movie and the Remake feature
characters being sucked into a new
reality where the stakes are life and
death so let's dive into all the Easter
eggs and details and make some guesses
about what exactly Dean shetty's long
game is we open on Kate restoring Emma's
memories of Sam the woods crawling
through that guy's brain and everything
else she'd forgotten over the past few
days Emma has a very ke reaction she
calls Kate a CA next Tuesday and takes
off to find Sam around the room we see
posters for dawn of the S and one that
says girls get it done which was the
slogan vot came up with during the short
period of time when there were three
women on the seven Kate has been pushing
too hard and she's doing some serious
damage that goes beyond just burst blood
vessels in her eyes it turns out she can
hear thoughts which is an element of her
powers we haven't seen before but we'll
get into why a little later Marie tells
Andre that getting into God you was the
best day of her life but then she
realized it wasn't any different than
the Red River Institute where she grew
up after accidentally killing her
parents this is similar to something
Starlight told huie and the boys about
how being admitted to the seven was
everything she'd worked toward before
realizing how awful it was the world of
vot and soups is just full of
disappointment now Marie has a lot of
empathy for Kate maybe because of what
she went through when she was younger
she says that they were all screwed over
and Kate is no different Andre ain't
convinced though but you know he was the
only one of them who was betrayed by
someone he was in love with Jordan calls
the others for help because Kate is
seizing and there's this hilarious
exchange can you learn CPR where at
superhero School Jesus yeah we know that
soups tend to end up causing a lot of
collateral damage even when they're just
going about their day-to-day lives so
honestly it wouldn't be a bad idea to at
least teach them basic first aid Marine
discovers yet another new element of her
powers when she speeds Kate's pulse up
essentially stabilizing her like a shot
of adrenaline in the the woods Dr
cardosa has made progress with this
virus successfully infecting a soup
named Betsy who seems to have
electricity Powers she's looking a bit
worse for wear and when she tries to use
her ability it just sort of Fizzles
which is the whole point of this cardosa
tells Shetty that non-powered humans
can't get infected because the virus
attaches to the compound V in the
bloodstream I hypothesized last episode
that Marie might be able to depower a
soup with her powers essentially
locating the v in their bloodstream and
burning it out of them and now I think
that she might be able to do the same
thing with this virus if a soup is
infected she could search for it in
their blood and potentially cure them
now when it's chilly outside I just want
to get cozy in my house and watch TV
without having to trudge down the street
for a latte and now thanks to ipsos I
say I can have my favorite coffee
delivered to me for free by using the
Visa gift card I get from answering
surveys ipsos is say lets you earn extra
cash through gift cards and rewards just
by taking part in research and answering
a few simple questions there's a ton of
different gift cards to choose from but
my favorite is the Visa I can use it
anywhere for anything which gives me the
most options to pick out free stuff for
myself the surveys on IPO they are quick
easy and tailored to my interest so it
never gets boring I do them while I'm
brushing my teeth or stuck on hold or
just have a few minutes to kill I
upgraded my down time so you can too
just click the link in the description
to start earning rewards with ipsos I
say today and also like I mentioned last
episode this virus does seem to be
similar to The Legacy virus from X-Men
which at first affected only mutants but
then mutated itself to begin infecting
humans this is why you got to be careful
with viruses as bioweapons folks you
never know how it's going to mutate
Shetty tells cardosa not to inform bot
of his Discovery but instead to
concentrate the do and see how sick they
can make Betsy now I have some thoughts
about what shed's up to and why later on
Andre moves Kate to a couch which
honestly he also probably shouldn't have
done don't these guys watch medical
shows and Kate makes everyone pass out
and gets stuck inside her mind including
poor Dusty who had the misfortune of
entering the room at the wrong time and
has no freaking clue what's going on
neither do the others though at first
especially when they start seeing
memories from Kate's childhood this is
similar to what Mindstorm did to butcher
in season three of the boys he trapped
butcher in an endless loop of bad
memories that he couldn't wake up from
we saw butcher lying unconscious just
like the gen V group does here in that
scenario Mindstorm did it on purpose but
he had years to perfect his abilities so
maybe Kate will get better at
controlling this down the line this is
very similar to the Scarlet Witch
attacking Professor Xavier when he was
inside her mind and Doctor Strange in
the Multiverse of Madness now back in
episode three Kate told Marie that when
she was nine she was camping with her
family when she told her annoying little
brother to go away and never come back
that was the first time her powers
manifested and despite everyone mounting
a search party her brother never showed
up we see the aftermath of that here in
Kate's first memory mommy it was an
accident why did have listen to me he
never does I don't feel safe with her
and then we get the Cameo everyone was
so excited about after last week's
preview Soldier Boy well it's kind of
soldja boy notice how he's introduced
with some kind of horn orchestration
what in the soldja boy it's kind of
like his Captain America
theme but yes this version of soldier
boy is actually Kate's imaginary friend
from when she was little and he's way
too excited to explain to everyone how
he helped Kate you know awaken sexually
you get it it's wrong lock this man up
up but the fact that he's like so loyal
to her kind of reminds me of the
imaginary boyfriend in Riley's mind and
Pixar's Inside Out but you know far less
wholesome he tells all of them that if
they don't figure out why Kate pulled
them in they'll get stuck in her mind
forever and as more and more blood
vessels burst in Kate's brain symbolized
by the flashes of lightning they keep
seeing higher the likelihood is that
they'll just be obliterated then the
single most important thing I can tell
you is yep classic and sure to make fans
Furious that they didn't get more gensen
aacle screen time now we should also say
that this episode using the setting of
collapsing memories is a conceit that
we've seen in titles like Inception
Eternal Sunshine at the Spotless Mind
Legion on FX which I think just edges
out the boys as the best superhero TV
series nothing against the MCU it's just
that the MCU has been better with
singular movies than episodic television
Daredevil season 1 is up there but so I
don't get yelled at they're all miles
behind Agents of
Shield but I just love the visual
aesthetic of how they show it here like
with the memories crumbling apart but
only having like a portal or a doorway
that assembles from The Broken Pieces
Just as a cool way of symbolizing how
Kate is always trying to find an exit
strategy from these haunting memories
meanwhile at the drive-in Sam eats the
Deep bot tots twists which seems to be
similar to Twizzlers but the container
he eats them out of has the same deep
puppet on it that Sam was imagining on
the TV a few episodes back so to me this
is strong evidence that there actually
is a bot's kids show starring Jason
Ritter in the boys universe and that it
wasn't just a hallucination completely
made up by Sam it's actually very
similar to how black noir took the
characters from Buster beavers and made
them part of his own Visions Emma comes
back to tell Sam she remembers
everything and they hug in front of this
claw machine game labeled polarity
magnetic Madness with what looks like
Funko and other toys and stuffed animals
inside maybe one of the funkos is of a
train Huey had one of those in his
bedroom in the boys if you remember Emma
and Sam get it on and it's his first
time which yeah he's been locked up
since he was kid makes sense the song
playe is 2017s don't delete the kisses
by wolf Alice the most interesting part
of the scene is when Emma turns into a
puppet in his mind not only is it a
hilarious visual it's also something
that Sam only seems to do when he is
stressed or in an unfamiliar situation
and we get this nice little puppet
homage to Titanic
where to miss to the stars back in
Kate's mind the group tries to figure
out what is happening while Dusty just
tries to keep up other than looking
young but actually being 28 we're still
not sure what his powers are he wears a
berserk t-shirt from the Japanese manga
series and a robe that says the Magic
Isle which you can actually buy from H&M
this is from their summer 2022 Magic
Isle capsule collection soups they're
just like us the next memory they see is
of a slightly older Kate getting a visit
from Dean Shetty Kate's parents have
kept her in a heavily locked and
fortified room room for 9 years and her
mom is still clearly terrified of her
which is just heartbreaking she's in a
perfect spot mentally to be manipulated
by Shetty but isn't it interesting that
her fortified armored room trapping her
inside is very similar to the security
protocol that is on all the dorm rooms
that God you like so that transition for
her wasn't that difficult and just a
remind her that all those students that
got you are probably going to end up
under lockdown at some point on her
walls there are various posters one for
the movie Queen mave Her Majesty one for
the movie whiskey Sunrise starring
Crimson Countess and a poster for a
soldier boy in Crimson countess romcom
which has them standing above a city
skyline distinct When Harry Met Sally
Vibes and also there's this poster of a
horse yeah Kate was totally a horse girl
who'd have guessed it Shetty goes full
court press on Kate telling her she's
not afraid of her saying it wasn't her
fault taking off her gloves and finally
offering a hug it's everything Kate has
ever wanted for the past nine years from
her mom so of course she's ready to do
anything Shetty tells her to do it's
interesting that shett seems unafraid of
suit Powers though the only soup she's
really seemed nervous around so far is
Tech Knight but maybe that's because his
power was the ability to see if she was
lying but let's not forget that Shetty
is a psychologist who is well-versed in
working with superpowered kids and young
adults so she's Adept at emotionally
controlling the soups it's possible that
she has some sort of immunity to them we
just don't know yet Kate says that the
voices she hears which I assume are
people's thoughts are so loud and Shetty
gives her a pill to take every day to
make them go away remember back in
episode 2 we saw a whole slew of pills
in Kate's room and she took one of these
blue ones so I guess they work and she's
been on them for years I wonder if these
pills are some sort of early mild form
of the virus that shed and card do have
been working on to dampen Powers this
whole scene has a major Dumbledore
meeting Tom Riddle vibe to it if you ask
me a trustworthy and Powerful adults
going to see a kid everyone is afraid of
to take them away to a school where they
will learn to use their powers hopefully
Kate doesn't turn into a Voldemort esque
monster like Tom Riddle did and yes this
is also the same process that every Jedi
did before Order 66 they took the
children in the next memory Kate meets
Luke who actually breaks to the memory
to talk directly to Andre we we should
we should leave I I can't be here I miss
man after this heartwarming declaration
he actually outs Andre to the others for
hooking up with Kate while Luke was
still alive and hindsight it did seem
like Andre and Kate got together very
soon after Luke's death so you know this
gives us a whole new perspective on the
overlapping period there Luke loses it
and ends up blasting poor Dusty who we
never see again this whole episode so
I'm not really clear on what happened to
him like if he really died in Kate's
mind wouldn't his body still be there
when the others wake up later was he
never really there to begin with it
might have always just been a projection
from Kate's mind maybe this will be
cleared up next episode everyone
realizes their powers ain't working here
so they outrun Luke and run right into
another memory this time it's one of
Jordan's we get to see both their male
Persona and their female Persona
together on screen for the first time
which is pretty cool apparently Kate can
pull memories from people's heads
because she wasn't even there to witness
this one Luke is screaming at Brink
demanding to see his brother and to know
the truth Brink injected him with
something to try to neutralize him but
apparently it wasn't strong enough so he
signals to Jordan to use the gas mask on
him and Jordan uses it to put loot down
as a thank you Brink gives Jordan the TA
position these m are showing us that all
of them have blood on their hands and
being mad at Kate is hypocritical
they've all betrayed someone or done
something terrible it's kind of like
that movie clue at the end where we see
the third scenario this is what really
happened and all of them kind of have
blood on their hands except Mr Green who
goes home to sleep with his wife I guess
Mr Green of this episode is either Sam
or Emma because they're the only ones
who haven't really done anything bad but
just like he did with Luke Brink brings
up the memory of recruiting Jordan when
they were just a scared kid to
manipulate them into doing what he wants
Kate's getting worse bleeding from her
eye and she pulls everyone into a memory
of the Woods Shetty cardosa and Brink
are transfusing blood from Sam into Luke
likely to try to make Luke stronger like
Brink wanted in episode one Brink
commented that Luke was burning stronger
than ever likely as a result of these
secret blood transfusions but Luke wakes
up Kate makes him forget that this is
happening to forget about the woods and
forget that Sam is still alive then we
see a bunch of instances where she made
him forget she tells shett and Brink
that it isn't working and Luke is
starting to remember despite her efforts
and Brink shrugs off her concerns and
Shetty looks directly at the others and
orders Kate to make them forget too they
run from her and into Marie's memory of
her parents right after she killed them
Annabeth is still sitting in the blood
and Marie tries to talk to her and
explain what happened and why this
tearful reunion leads to Marie forgiving
herself she didn't understand her powers
and neither did Kate who was the first
person to tell her that all of this
wasn't her fault she tells Kate to wake
up with them because they are all messed
up in the overhead shot of Kate's room
there is a cold snap comic on the desk
we saw Colt snap in season 3 of The Boys
At herogasm and it looked like he
survived Soldier Boy's explosion because
he was being carted away on a stretcher
at at the end of that episode Andre
takes a different approach than Marie
and yells at Kate that she has a choice
and she needs to choose to wake up and
you know what that works everyone wakes
up shaken and Confused not sure what is
real kind of like the people who wake up
on the floor after a major trippy
Inception but their powers are back so
that's how they know they're officially
out of the weird mind prison isn't that
kind of a bummer that this curse you
were born with is the only way you know
that you're alive now there's some weird
cuts and Jordan Kate and Marie go to the
area where we last Saw Dusty before Kate
vanished and the Mind Games began but
there is no mention of Dusty Justice for
Dusty it's also possible that the guy
was just a red shirt who is added in to
up the stakes and tension of this
episode but I just think it's one of
those weird production or editing things
Emma and Sam burst in and Sam
understandably flips out when he sees
Kate and needs to be talked down from
the edge while he's busy tossing
everyone around like ragd dolls or I
guess like puppets there's a poster on
the wall for the movie big crazy love
and on it written in marker Sloan was
here Sloan was the alpaca that we saw
last episode so this seems to confirm
that Sloan might be a soup that can turn
into an alpaca or soup that can turn
into different animals you know like the
animars it's just because an alpaca
definitely would have such nice
handwriting they're they're you know
hooved Marie wants Kate to tell them
about the woods and Sam says Shetty had
them doing bad stuff to everyone down
there she hates us Shetty was directing
it all and back in the woods cardosa is
freaking out and tells Shetty that he
was just following orders and we know
who else historically is used that as an
excuse yeah maybe you are the bad guy
here dude the concentrated dose of the
virus killed Betsy who is covered in
blood and boils and Shetty isn't
horrified she's excited and I like how
the sound swells and it drops out right
before she says her final line so that
it lands like a ton of
bricks now can you make it contagious oh
my God and we end on the Bengals Hazy
Shade of Winter playing over the credits
so what exactly is shed's deal and how
does it tie into the larger boys
universe is she just another vot puppet
that's following orders or is she
playing her own game well I think the
answer lies and something she said to
Marie a few episodes back she mentioned
a daughter and when Marie asked her
about it she responded that she had a
daughter past tense my guess is that her
daughter died from something they soup
did some collateral damage from a
mission gone wrong maybe even some event
that we've heard mentioned before in the
boys that loss instilled Shetty and
intense hatred of soups just like Sam
said she hates us I think that vot
doesn't actually know about the woods or
the experiments going on down there I
mean think about it there is no way vot
would want a transmissible virus on the
loose that could cost them their biggest
assets a decent way to control them or
dampen their powers sure but they
definitely wouldn't want something as
unpredictable as a virus out in the
world maybe Shetty just made cusa think
that this was all on the up and up she
made him think that this virus was all
the way to control soups to depower them
for periods of time when in actuality
her true goal is to wipe all of them out
exterminate them all if this is the case
this would be a very interesting
parallel to the boys and the boys we are
meant to empathize with those who have
been affected by the soups and see their
side of things soups are destructive and
hedonistic and innocent people get
caught in their Crossfire so when one of
the soups is killed it kind of feels
like justice but on gen B we've spent
all season getting to know these young
soups they're relatable issues and
insecurities and honestly if one of them
dies I'm going to be crushed protect
Emma at all costs so now we see the
other side of the coin soups and their
unchecked power are destructive but so
is all consuming hatred of them Shetty
doesn't want their powers taken away she
wants them dead even the ones who
haven't done anything wrong and I think
that unless our soups can get a handle
on their powers and get over their
issues they are in for a very very bad
and boil filled time let me know in the
comments below what you think about this
Shetty Theory is it a shete theory or a
theory subscribe to new rockstars
in the Deep dive in the break room and
you can support us by grabbing some
merch over at nerd r. shop follow me at
EA boss follow new rockstars And
subscribe to new rockstars for more
analysis of everything you love thanks
for watching
[Music]
bye